morning at this altitude i can run flat
out for a while before my hands start
shaking the Royals people quickly now
[Music]
cybernetic organisms living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by for sig mattock I
reached out to these finish
entrepreneurs after a very talented
Acrobat introduced me to one of their
products which blew my mind in the best
way possible it is mushroom coffee what
on earth is this well it includes chaga
mushroom very powerful antioxidant
considered a superfood I was introduced
to chaga by Laird Hamilton the king of
big-wave surfing of all things and it
includes another mushroom that is
considered a no tropic a smart drug and
this is lion's mane in the entire
package just added to hot water tastes
like coffee there is only 40 milligrams
of caffeine so less than half what you
would find in a cup of coffee so you I
do not get any jitters I do not get any
acid reflux or any type of stomach burn
and it put me on fire for an entire day
and I only had half of the packet so
this stuff is really amazing people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement right now this is
the answer so it is legal it will not
give you visuals that's something else
and you can try it right now by going to
force Sigma tech comm /em that is for
sig matic SI GM atic for sick matic calm
forward slash Tim and use the code Tim
to get twenty percent off your first
order if you are in the experimental
mindset i do not think you'll be
disappointed for sig matic com4 / tip
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront is the future of
financial advice that become incredibly
popular among my friends in Silicon
Valley and across the country because
they provide the same high-end financial
advice that the best private wealth
managers delivered to the ultra wealthy
but for any account size and at a
fraction of the cost for instance they
monitor your portfolio every day across
more than a dozen asset classes to look
for opportunities to rebalance or
harvest tax losses now would you do the
same are you doing the same probably not
and the powers in the software
wealthfront now manages more than four
billion dollars in assets which is up
from around 2.5 billion when they
started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned private wealth
matters wealthfront is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax-efficient low-cost hassle-free way
to invest they don't have bloated sales
teams or retail locations so they can
deliver all of this sophisticated
financial advice and these services at a
fraction of the cost of a traditional
financial advisor so the very least go
to wealthfront calm forward slash tim
and take their free risk assessment
survey it only takes a couple of minutes
and well front will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money so even
if you don't use their service you have
a huge leg up and you have additional
information for making good decisions
they use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make but
should so go too well front calm forward
slash Tim to get your first 15k managed
for free or just to get more details
check it out well front calm forward
slash Tim
hello boys and girls this is comparison
i'm recording this introduction inside a
phone booth literally to the tim ferriss
show welcome back every episode it is my
job to deconstruct a world-class
performer from any given field could be
sports chef entertainment business or
otherwise and this episode's going to be
a little bit different this is a
follow-up episode by popular demand and
don't worry it doesn't matter if your
motion to the first episode or not
although you should so back by popular
demand Caroline Paul returns to the
podcaster around two she is answering
your most popular question that's
uploaded and this is a standalone piece
you can enjoy it by itself caroline is
the author for published books your
latest is New York Times bestseller the
gusty girl subtitle escapades for your
life with epic adventure I read this I'm
not a gutsy girl try to be gutsy dude
but it is fantastic it is not
necessarily gender specific and there's
a lot to learn from Caroline so she's be
afraid of a lot of things then she
decided the fear got in the way of the
life she wanted one of excitement
confidence and self reliance she has
since flown planes rapid huge rivers
quite gigantic objects mountains golden
gates which you don't recommend and
fought fires is one of the very first
female firefighters in San Francisco she
is amazing and she is very wicked writer
and teacher so in this episode Caroline
answers many different questions and
addresses many different topics
including the best starting point for
overcoming your fears there are many
times that I can use this myself how to
stay focused in the moment and not let
your mind create anxiety and stress
useful from you this week in particular
her biggest life-changing experiences
coping strategies for dealing with
life's most difficult events and much
much more so please enjoy this round to
QA with Caroline Paul hi this is
Caroline Paul and I'm really happy to be
back with all of you and Tim on the Tim
Ferriss podcast for round two and you
sent me a bunch of questions and I'm
going to answer some of them thanks so
much let's just dive right in so no name
asked if you're trying to change your
relationship with fear where do you
start
it's hard to face it when it's breathing
down on you any tips well first of all
congratulations on changing your
relationship to fear I don't know if
you're a woman but if you are this is an
especially big step because as I've
talked about I feel really strongly that
we as women have been so encouraged to
be fearful that it's an underpinning of
our life that were often not even
conscious of so just taking this step is
amazing here's my tip it's really
straightforward micro bravery because
here's a concept that a great
organization called girls leadership
really articulate it to me which is that
bravery is learned and like anything
learned it just needs to be practiced
and the way we practice things is to
start small so micro bravery this is
what they call it I love that micro
bravery is basically breaking down your
fears into either smaller steps or just
start starting small with any fear and
the reason we want to do that is because
well first of all you become aware of
what it feels like to be fearful because
here's the truth and I think I talked
about this on the podcast before but
fear feels a lot like excitement has the
same physiological characteristics of a
high heart rate to sweat nervous tension
and so often what we do especially as
women because we're really not taught to
discern the nuances of fear because we
aren't taught to value bravery like men
are so we aren't taught to really move
through it is that it feels so similar
to excitement that we often mistake the
fact that we're not actually completely
subsumed with abject fear we actually
are feeling fear and other things
excitement exhilaration anticipation
curiosity things that really will open
up our life and that actually is telling
us hey this this new experience is going
to be kind of cool but because and again
often it's women we don't
we haven't practiced bravery so we don't
really understand what we're feeling in
times of stress or where we're pushing
outside we're comfort zone so when you
practice bravery and really what you're
practicing is micro bravery you get
really comfortable and you start to
understand what fear feels like and you
start to discern all the nuances of that
emotion so the second thing you become
knowledgeable about is what bravery is
because I think a lot of women don't
really have a sense of what that feels
like either in fact I like to to turn
around maybe even this question and say
well it's not really changing a
relationship to fear it's changing a
relationship to bravery and so what
we're doing and I know I talked about
this before is it we are valuing a
bravery paradigm instead of a fear
paradigm because I do think we give
permission to women to talk about fear a
lot and to really emphasize it in ways
that make it that perpetuates it the
last thing you do is when you're
practicing micro bravery you really
start to develop a process of moving
from fear to bravery and that process
when you use it in small instances you
can apply when you confront fear in
bigger instances and that can be an
emotional fear and that can be fear you
know in in your workplace and that can
also be fear in the outdoors now when
you practice micro bravery I really want
kids to practice it in the outdoors
because it's really fun the outdoors and
it's a really great way to understand
that line between being scared and then
excitement and then going to bravery
because it's just more obvious and if
you're trying to practice and in a more
emotional situation but as adults I know
you already know whether you like the
outdoors or not
is not about like oh you have to be in
the outdoors to be brave not true you
guys who are not so much outdoors you
can practice in at home or in the
workplace small acts of micro bravery
again really important this is something
you start small so that you really get
to know yourself and bravery better an
analogy might be deciding you're going
to run at 5k you don't just go run a 5k
on the day of the race you practice and
you practice in small increments you
start by walking you start then you
proceed to running a little bit you get
the picture so it's you breaking it down
and in that way your training and your
training to understand your body like a
runner and you're treating to understand
your own mind so Hayley Harris bloom
asks caroline is Indy all thank you and
Caroline is it being incredible glad
you're bringing your back thank you what
suggestions does Caroline have to those
who work in the emergency medical
community well first I'd say realize
that we are in a Shakespearean
profession as emergency responders what
I mean by that is that all these calls
you go on our high drama it's what
you're seeing is def destruction
betrayal birth intrigue and that's not
only tremendously powerful view into
humanity it's also an opportunity to
really make yourself better I mean
because trust me if you're on the
streets like I was you're seeing vast
array of humanity and in its glory and
inhale it's real sadness actually so in
some ways s annex really a privilege
that frankly I think we often forget
about so in order to really be inspired
by our job and not burnt out by it i
would say that remember that the small
gestures are so important this is
something that i wish that i had
been more aware of at the time that and
it comes from an experience I actually
had and I had been retired as a
firefighter but I was flying my
experimental plane and i had a bad
accident was humiliating and it was also
terrifying and i was packaged up and put
into the ambulance and i was being taken
care of by a young paramedic i remember
his name Nicholas and he was so
compassionate he was so caring he could
have been my I was old enough to be his
mom and but he was so careful with
everything he did he would put his hand
on my shoulder he would lean over me
when he talked because I couldn't move
because I was it was in c-spine and
packaged really tightly because of my
injuries you would make sure that he
that we that we saw each other's eyes
and he talked to me and his tone of
voice was so comforting and I remember
he used these endearment with me
sweetheart dear and usually I kind of
find that annoying but it was so calming
for me and I was so grateful for how
present he was and how careful he wasn't
carrying he was and it made me wonder
like right in that ambulance was I this
good as a firefighter did I treat the
people that I came in contact with with
this sort of compassion and I don't
think I ever realize until I was in this
accident myself just how scared people
are at this moment in their life and how
much of a difference one person one
young handsome half my age paramedic how
much of a difference he's made I still
remember him all these years later and
I'm so grateful for him and so it's
those gestures it's so small gestures
except being present that matter I know
that that person with the heart
palpitations is the umpteenth person
with heart palpitations that you've
probably had maybe that even that week
but for her it's the most
matic time of her life and we can make
such a difference in that moment and
that is so powerful the other thing is
is that we have to make meaning of these
calls because often they feel so chaotic
and cruel and I remember a fire that I
went to it was started by a guy who had
been sleeping on the couch and he woke
up and I think he dropped a cigarette
but anyway the place is on fire and
instead of warning the people in he just
ran out and this was really
disheartening because those six people
were missing when the fire was out and
the chief came to us the rescue squad
and said hey we got six people missing
and we need you to do a search and when
you do a search in a house that's had a
fire what you're doing is you're on your
hands and knees combing through debris
it's like looking for a contact lens but
what you're looking for is people you're
pushing aside everything and we found
them we found them in two areas it was
one women woman and with two kids and
then in the other corner of the room it
was another woman with the other two
kids and it was really clear by their
the way they were lying that those women
were trying to shield those kids they
had gathered those kids in their arms
they had maybe even went after those
kids to try to just be with them when
they died I don't know the whole story
but the meaning i put to it is that
those women were heroic and in those
last moments those women also comforted
the children and died together and it
showed me that amid the unfairness and
the cowardliness these women were heroes
and that there was love at the end and
that even in the most
stressful circumstances like when a fire
is barreling down on you you will gather
kids in your arms and they will be your
last thought and somehow that gives our
whole job you know meaning good meaning
and I think it keeps emergency workers
like you and like me from total burnout
hi Rebecca Faber you ask what's the best
gift to get firefighters I have to
firefighting brothers and I want to
eventually buy them something that's not
booze related okay well I'm actually not
very materialistic so I might not be the
best person asus but I have to say that
I do love old fire gear you can find old
nozzles and old fireboxes and old fire
extinguishers online and also on flea
markets and so I actually have a small
collection myself I would also say that
your brothers would like shirts and ball
caps from other fire departments
stations sell them at least here in San
Francisco separately each have their own
distinct logos and that could be really
cool because especially if you walk into
a firehouse and ask for this and then
have an interaction with a firefighter
and tell your brother's about it that's
even a bigger part of the gift finally
I'd say one gift that you might not
think about but would be great this
isn't really for an occasion but maybe
read yourself about the job of
firefighting because I think
firefighters would really appreciate
when their family members seem to
understand a little more about what's
going on the job and you'd be surprised
how much you pick up from memoirs and
books that that talk about what
firefighters do even if your brothers
aren't in those departments even if
they're not in a big city department
there's so much similar that happens
partly because the traditions run so
deep so I myself wrote a book about
firefighting
I've read a lot of them and we often
tell very similar stories about what
goes on in the fire the antics in the
firehouse and also some of the horrors
of our calls and someone the poignancy
of our calls and the deepness of our
bond so reading books would be a gift
that you can give your brothers even
though they might not even know it but
do that and give them those sweatshirts
Jeff urban asks how do you stay rooted
in the present you seem very focused hi
Jeff well I've always been focused but I
have to say I haven't always been rooted
I am very goal-oriented so if I want
something done I set deadlines and I'm
really specific about it so for my books
if I I want to have a book bought so
then I plan my book proposal and I say
when is it going to be done and I stick
to that and if necessary I write it down
so that I really know so it's not just a
mushy idea in my mind it's there on the
paper and I can see it I it's called
sort of how many by when when you're
really specific about your goals I think
that's really important I don't have a
mouth patient practice or breath
practice I wish I did I do it sometimes
but what I do have is a really
structured day and so I I get a lot done
because I don't get distracted a lot and
by the way there is a flip side to this
which means I can be inflexible and I'm
really that's something I'm working on
because I think that there is value in
being loser even though in my life I've
gotten a lot done by being more what
Wendy my partner calls rigid and I call
disciplined or as you call it focused
the other thing I do and this may lead a
little more to rootedness is that I
don't schedule too much in a day I
always put in a padding between things
because that means I'm not frazzled and
I think
frazzled leads to unrooted pneus you
might still be focused when you're
frazzled but you're not going to be
rooted it's probably one of the reasons
that I like adventure so much because I
think that's where focus and rootedness
intersect because I can be outside and
that's where I often find my rootedness
and a lot of times the high adrenaline
of the situation will really make me
focus so for instance when I'm surfing
and I'm not a good surfer but I really
love being outside in the water and I'm
a really competent paddler and swimmer
so I find that's where I get most rooted
and most focus because I'm focused
because I'm not that good and I don't
want to get hammered by a wave I'm
always looking and you know scrapping
over a wave scrabbling over a wave try
not to fall off the lip try to get over
when I'm going out if there's no channel
which is often there isn't and then if
I'm actually trying to catch a wave it's
paddling looking back paddling and
that's all I'm thinking about not
thinking about anything else I am super
focused and i'm rooted because i'm
really physically rooted in my body and
also to nature and I just feel quite
complete I don't I'm not really thinking
about anything else but those that
simple movement of catching the wave
jumping up trying to move the board and
doing it all again and the partly the
simplicity of that movement is also very
brooding and one of the big reasons why
I really like surfing even though you
can't really do it that well and one of
the things that a habit I have that I
think really helps keep my day focused
is that I when I have to go somewhere I
don't think of the time I have to be
there I think about the time but I have
to leave to be there and one more thing
on focus and the writing down and having
a goal is that you know I don't know if
you've ever ridden horses
but when I was young we had horses and
my mother used to say when you're
writing make sure that you look where
you want your horse to go because your
horse can feel where you're looking and
that's what they're responding to and I
think it's the same with us as people we
need to always have our eye on what we
where we want to go when we take our eye
off that we are going to veer away from
that path so if I'm veering away not
getting something that I want that I'm
focused on that I working hard towards I
really look like sure I really on that
really because your horse is going the
other way and it's really helpful so
thanks Jeff I appreciate that question
the next question is from Pine and an
tous I'd be interested to know what your
coping strategies are for being exposed
to horrific human events how do you
persevere well as a firefighter one
thing I came away with was a realization
the tragedies are the result of a series
of small Forks in the road they're not
usually just one sudden catastrophic
event preceding them has come a series
of small decisions that have led up to
this one big moment and so from this
realization that life is very much
random and haphazard and chaotic and out
of our control is puny humans I did take
some solace in the fact that maybe I
could just make those small decisions a
little better and the way I do that is
this theory of the checklist it's
something that doctors have come upon
quite recently and that pilots have been
using forever which is the idea that
even as experienced as you are you need
to stick to a checklist in certain
decisions because if you don't you will
you will one day make a small error and
that will lead to a very big mistake so
as pilots we walk into our hangars and
I've been flying since I was 18 and I
still pick up my checklist and walk to
my experimental and go through my
experimental using that checklist to
make sure it's flyable
do not deviate from that because I know
that as a human as experienced as I am
one of these days I'm going to make a
mistake and forget something and that'll
be the day that there'll be a mechanical
error similarly I pour this in my sort
of day-to-day life in that I always wore
my seatbelt I know that sounds weird but
some people do say like oh you know I'm
only going half a block but I've seen
really bad accidents within half a block
but not only that what I've seen is that
there's this erosion where you drive
half a block without your seatbelt then
you get into that habit and then you
start maybe driving across town without
your seatbelt and then you go on a long
trip so of course you put on your
seatbelt the next time your trips not so
long and you don't blah blah blah it's
it gets so that one of these days you're
going to make the wrong decision and
you're going to have your seatbelt off
when that car comes barreling at you and
so that's why I just simply decide that
some of these very small decisions I'm
going to have under my control and I'm
going to try to make them consistently
not haphazard Lee so that when the fates
decide to intervene that I have a pretty
good chance of coming out okay and I
really think that was one of the biggest
things that I came away with when seeing
what you call these horrific human
events and they were is that they feel
whimsical and chaotic and random but if
I can just be really mindful of those
smaller decisions and I'm not
overwhelmed by this idea that a piano
might fall from a building onto my head
which sometimes seem to be the way life
was for a lot of people and I could
persevere through what you call these
horrific events thanks so much for that
question hi Jason you asked how do you
recommend avoiding gender bias with kids
ie clothes toys etc you know I just
learned this astounding fact and that is
that many of the G movies that the
little kids in our lives are seen
completely underrepresented and girls by
a large proportion so this sort of
gender bias is starting really really
young the statistics said that even in
crowd scenes women make up only
seventeen percent and even the animals
that are in kids movies are portrayed as
male and to me that's just kind of
mind-blowing how we begin to undervalue
and underrepresented women at such a
young age and in every single corner of
life even a crowd scene anyway so that's
what we're up against here when we're
talking gender bias I don't really have
any quick solutions for this except to
say that we should also be very aware
that it starts at home you and I are
both guilty of this I think I want to
talk about this in the previous episode
but studies show that we treat our girls
differently than our boys for instance
on the playground we caution them much
more even though they're physically as
equal as the boys we already have an
idea of their abilities or their
inabilities and we are telling them in
all these different ways and
understanding ourselves so for instance
one thing that tries me crazy and I'm
especially sensitive to this is when
people use the word fireman and I know
it's only three letters fireman but when
you see as the man to fireman instead a
firefighter what you're giving two kids
is just this picture of a man all the
time as a firefighter and they never it
really doesn't sink in even now that
women are firefighters and same with
police men and police officers its
police officers because when you say
police men you are giving an idea that
men can only are the only contain gender
that can be police police officers so we
have to start at home after all
behemoth that were fighting that's the
media is really hard even for us to
discern I don't know if you realize how
underrepresented women are in adult
adult themed films to you know in PG an
r-rated films we are hardly ever stars
the our professions sock on film we
usually don't speak and when we do is
usually about our relationships or we're
even if you're the star often if you're
in a scene with men they will speak more
they will be given more lines and all
this is none of this is malice this is
all unconscious stuff that we're
perpetuating and then our kids see and
then they grow up with and I have to
emphasize that we really need to teach
our boys to about this and I wrote an
essay on this for Ted calm but one thing
is that we really want our boys to be
reading books about girls not just girls
reading books about boys and again it's
just a broad in their idea of what the
genders can do and I got a letter
actually from a woman who bought gutsy
girl for her niece because she said that
her niece was quote scared of her own
shadow and she thought that this book
would inspire her and they read it the
niece came and visited and they read it
together and I'm sure they thought the
writing was awesome and and that those
stories were good but really the change
that came over her over that week was
less from actually just sort of reading
a good book than being inspired by role
models for one and for two the fact that
this concept was introduced of gutsiness
but suddenly this girl understood that
there was this idea of how she could be
and she began even using that nauman
clay sure and her aunt sent me a photo
of her in a tree but that she had
climbed looking super proud and said
that she had also been petting animals
and learning to hit a tennis ball
things like that which really opened up
this girl's life and so having role
models and giving kids more concept than
the narrow ones we get from the media
also super important hi Katerina you
asked you shared so many adventures in
the first episode but I feel like you
have so many more what adventures have
been most life-changing for you and why
I feel like I've spoken about the
obvious life-changing ones is the ones
where i rarely escaped death or injury i
wrote about most of those in the gutsy
girl and i talked about them so on a
subtler level i will say by the way that
most adventures offer me some one or
more epiphanies which is why i do
adventures but what i remember is when i
went on a sea kayak trip down the coast
of Baja and I wasn't an expert sea
kayaker and neither was my friend but we
we read this book that this woman had
written about her own sea kayak trip
down Baja and she listed the routes
where you pull into camp what you would
need to bring how did you get down there
and we followed that book to the tee and
we had our own just great adventure
because it was Baja which is just
rampant wilderness we saw nobody for the
first seven days of our of our of
paddling and we had to bring all our
water and it was pristine ocean and so
much wildlife and really was just a huge
adventure and it wasn't like we were
expert sea kayakers we had taught
ourselves how to navigate but I remember
on the second leg so we did 17 de leg
and then we pulled out hitchhiked back
to our car drove down to another part of
Baja and did another trip that she had
outlined for us in her book and we ran
into this group of expert sea kayakers
they were from the Bay Area they were
they were paddling Association
they have stuff with quite a bit of
disdain do you know how to roll and both
church and I looked in like no we don't
know how to roll our fully loaded with
water sea kayaks and they said if you
don't know how to roll you shouldn't be
down here and at first I was really
taken aback and thought wow wonder if
they're right and and I the more I
thought about it the more I realized
that I could understand their point they
were basically saying you can't be a
yahoo when you go on trips we're already
kind of Yahoo we were doing this from a
book but we were also competent we knew
how to paddle we knew how to swim we
were really good outdoors people we had
taught ourselves to use a compass on a
kayak we understood the weather this is
well before cell phones but in fact we
had really taken care of pretty much
everything and rolling was not it would
have been great but it wasn't something
that should have stopped us from this
trip and what I remember thinking is wow
you know I bet there's a lot of people
who stop themselves from doing things
because they just don't think they're
expert enough and while I think you you
need to be really sure that you can
handle things you don't have to be an
expert on everything there is a point
where people are like planning and
planning and preparing a prayer and they
never actually do their adventure or
they just never do their adventure
because they don't think it's possible
for them when it is possible with a book
and with the right mindset the right
adventure partner and the right basic
set of skills I guess Tim talks about
this like what is the stuff that will
what is the percentage of thing you need
to know the least percentage in order to
have the best time and I think that
rolling was not part of that and years
later in fact I went on a sea kayak trip
with two friends and again we just
looked at maps and went from island to
island in Belize and this time we were
on sit on top and sit on tops
our have no deck so I mean rolling is
not even part of the equation when you
see kayak like that so i would say that
in terms of life changing it made me
realize that you know nirsa is a
powerful force to stop you from having
adventures because you have if you can
get some time off work and get a little
money together and have the right person
all the other tools are at your
fingertips at least they were for me and
for that I'm super grateful hi sumeet
how are you have I you have a ton of
questions that's nice but you're going
to ask one it looks like 11 would be
about your nighttime routine how do you
slow down at night and prepare for the
next day well my nighttime routine is to
try to get to bed as early as possible
because I'm the most productive in the
morning and I'm not a night person so in
some ways my night routine isn't of use
because I just simply get tired I don't
sleep that well but I do get tired so a
couple things I don't drink water before
certain after a certain time so I have
to get up in the middle of the night to
pee do not do that I also don't look at
screens about a half hour before i go to
sleep you know after the show when i
talked about how difficult it was for me
to get a good night's sleep i got some
people getting in touch with me about
sleeping well which is my next step to
look into but for now my major concern
is all as my morning because i really
really want to feel good in the morning
thanks for your question hi Kelsey you
asked about flying you say you mentioned
an episode one about flying but I was
curious why did you start flying I think
I started flying because I remember one
very specific flying dream when I was a
kid I was flying like Superman which is
what we used to watch when we were kids
and it was over a city at night those
all lights and it just looks so
beautiful and I think I almost had that
in my mind as well as the fact that
flying seemed to be the
most adventure and I had heard of Amelia
Earhart when I was a kid she was a
female adventurer so I think that also
meant that for me flying was an option I
mean I had this great role model of
outdoor adventure so I began flying
Cessnas when I was 18 and even though I
love that feeling of loosing from the
earth and looking down and seeing that
panorama below flying Cessnas never
really was made me that intrigued
because as I say in the book it wasn't
really like flying like a bird it was
more like flying in a can of soup so I
changed to paragliders which was a new
sport at the time when I picked it up
very new and it had been invented by
climbers who wanted to get off a
mountain without having to climb down so
they basically designed this sort of
wing like parachute and that has a good
glide ratio so I food paralyzed for many
years and I loved it because it was
silent and I and you really did feel
like you're flying like a bird I flew in
Mexico and in Brazil and along the
cliffs in California and then at some
point I decided after I had had many
knee surgeries from being a firefighter
that I should probably switch to powered
flight again but not Cessnas because
they didn't interest me and I had long
been intrigued by what they called then
ultra lights and so I became a pilot of
these hang gliders with go carts
underneath them and lawn mower motors is
basically what they look like and that's
what I fly now and I love it it's it's
exhilarating to look down on the earth
from that perspective and the thing
about weight shift trikes which is what
we call these hang glider type
contraptions is that you can fly very
low and slow so you see a lot of things
I've see coyotes I see leopard sharks
I see incredible mansions over in the
Napa Valley and see all different kinds
of landscapes the ocean the sort of
rolling hills of California and lots and
lots of vineyards so it's a beautiful
way to get a perspective on things and
when I go flying I often feel like all
my problems are so small because I see
from above just how big the world seems
and how insignificant i do and that's
that's a prospective changer for me the
thing about flying though is that it is
kind of lonely because when you're up
there you are very alone if something
happens nobody can help you and it's
sobering that way but it's lonely in a
in a sort of existential way which I
think I've always liked and then there
are moments when you you do remember
that you're actually not alone up there
I remember when I heard over the radio a
pilot calling in a mayday he had
something wrong with this plan I don't
remember what it was but he was going to
come in straight in landing to the
airport could everybody please get out
of his way and you could hear the
tension at his voice and the trepidation
and then another voice came on and it
was another pilot and he said really
commonly hey buddy you're going to be
fine just remember to use your checklist
remember to you know da da da and I
remember thinking okay even in the most
loneliest scariest moments you know
somebody can come in call me down and
remind you to do the right steps because
this is the time when you're well I want
to make a mistake I myself had engine
issues once and I remember watching the
temperatures rise on my panel and
thinking I'm gonna have to ditch but
ditching is not an decisions not really
the right word when you're talking about
a hang glider with a motor we do have a
glide ratio so but i was still gonna
have to make an emergency landing if i
didn't make it to the nearest airport
and I knew where the nearest airport was
so I thought it's not I really don't
want to make an emergency landing I've
done those before and they can get
really hairy so let's try to make it to
the airport before my
engine seizes so I'm looking at my
interim panel and i'm heading right to
the airport and I call in like that
other guy did keeping my voice as calm
as possible saying I have an engine
problem I'm coming straight in please
please clear the way if anybody's in the
traffic pattern and it was a rinky-dink
airport and it was dusk and I didn't get
that soothing voice over the over the
radio telling me that everything was
going to be okay I didn't get anybody
nobody heard me I'll and my engine does
not fees it's completely overheating
though I get out I'm so relieved and I
look over and I see a light in a hangar
and I walk over and I say as
nonchalantly as possible and a little
difficulty had to make an emergency
landing here and he said oh come bring
your plane in you can keep it here
overnight and I'll take you back to your
Airport and of course when you're a
pilot and you're hanging with other
pilots that doesn't mean you're getting
a car it means you get into a super
tricked low wing aerobatic plane and he
flies you back to your Airport and you
realize at once first of all how close
that call was and secondly you know what
a great community pilots pilots are so
flying has really offered me not only
adventure but in moments of poignancy
and moments of relief but also these
moments of great camaraderie hi William
and see you want to know was there any
moment when you became trapped or needed
rescue yourself and how did this affect
you and how did you move forward from
there when I was a firefighter I never
needed anybody to rescue me and in most
of my adventures when I did get myself
into a hairy situation i did get myself
out but there was one instance on the
mountain of Denali where I did need
rescue and it taught me a very huge
lesson actually to in fact I talked
about this incident and my book the
gutsy girl so I'll be quick about it if
you want to read about it please pick up
the book but Denali is a mountain in
Alaska and it's known to Mountaineers
for it's very dangerous weather but the
year I went
went actually twice but this one year I
went as a volunteer to help the park
rangers at base camp at 8,000 because
one of my very good friends Eric was one
of the kick-ass emergency paramedic
rescue paramedics very brave guy super
great Mountaineer so it was me Trish and
Eric and that year was really warm so we
decided that we would ski from base camp
at 8,000 to 14,000 because this terrible
weather Denali was known for suddenly
wasn't happening so we began our ascent
using skins and rope together like
Mountaineers do and the nightmare
happened Eric fell in a crevasse and who
I was only competent in rope rescue
because I had been a long time member of
rescue two and we were very well trained
in rope rescue but there's a big
difference in performing rope rescue
when you're an urban firefighter with 10
of your friends who've trained with you
and there's a big big fire engine with a
big bumper that you can attach your rope
to as an anchor in this situation it was
just snow and so I had to set up an
anchor to stabilize Eric and Trish who
were both on the rope and pull Eric up
who was not responding and so for all we
knew he was dead and making an anchor
and that kind of snow was so brutal for
me because the snow was so soft what I
learned was that because I wasn't
experienced I was relying on my narrow
range of knowledge to set this anchor
and it will all the traditional methods
weren't working well because how soft
the snow was and I sometime in the
middle of this terrible ordeal where
we're setting up an anchor and beginning
and and not not as anchor that we were
sure of in the end and then trying to
begin our leverage system to pull Eric
up Trish yells they
that there were climbers coming and that
they could help us and the first thing I
said to her is no way we're doing this
ourselves now my friend eric is dangling
at the end unresponsive in a deep
crevasse we know he's badly hurt if he's
not dead even and the first thing I
think of when I see rescue is no way we
have to do this ourselves hurry up that
is the wrong attitude and Trish was
rightly really angry at me and said
we're in trouble and we need these
people and she was right and even though
as an outdoors person I have a very
strong belief that we had have to get
ourselves out of the situations we get
ourselves into well I was not doing it
and we needed the help and sure enough
these climbers come and they give us the
meet the look of disdain that we
deserved for being unable to handle
these conditions that were unexpected
and difficult and they pulled Erik out
and when he got to the surface and
gained consciousness he was really badly
he had a very bad head wound was not
altogether there but the first thing he
said to me is do not call a helicopter
please do not call a helicopter all ski
down and I looked them and I knew
exactly where he was coming from he
didn't want to be rescued either he
didn't want to be humiliated in front of
his peers he knew that if you were an
outdoors person and you got yourself
into something you had to get yourself
out you wanted to ski down and I just
looked at him and I said I know honey I
know exactly what you're talking about
but we're calling that helicopter so
there's a lot of lessons on pride there
and look I might have been you know I
rope person because I was a firefighter
in a big city but what I lacked was a
specific experience on the mountain and
so what I didn't have was a nimble mind
I kept trying to use the techniques that
I had been taught in crevasse rescue
because I had I had done some practice
crevasse training of course but I kept
using those
same techniques that I had been taught
to try to set this anchor that took so
long to set because of the terrible snow
when I should have immediately been way
more nimble mentally and seen that what
I was doing wasn't working and I had
would have to get creative and the way
you get creative and what any really
good mountain here would have done she
would have immediately taken off her ski
and seen what her ski could do and
buried it in the snow and use that as an
anchor because when you bury a ski
perpendicularly snow it acts like what
we call a Deadman a completely secure
anchor because of the way that it
leverages against the snow you bury it
perpendicular so any any pulling on it
it just that sexy will not dislodge no
matter how soft that snow is but of
course I wasn't that Mountaineer I was a
person who learned by the book and was
trying to execute by the book even
though nothing about the situation was
by the book as they never are in the
wilderness and what I learned now if i
ever get myself into that situation
again i will be very quick to see
whether i am simply trying to do the
same lame thing over and over or whether
i should be trying to think outside the
box and blow apart the box that i've
been taught to find new creative ways to
get myself out of that situation and
that's that's when you ask how did I
what did I take away from that those are
the two things pride and get creative
because what you learn in perfect
situation is not going to be what you
can apply when things hit the fan and on
that note I'll wrap it up you guys have
more questions but they pretty much
covered all that territory so thanks so
much for listening i can't tell you how
much I appreciate it thank you
hey guys this is Tim again a few more
things before you take off number one
this is 508 Friday do you want to get a
short email for me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and 500 Friday
is a very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that have
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do it could include
favorite articles that i have read and
that i've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to four hour work week dot com
that's four hour work week com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
wealthfront is the future of financial
advice they become incredibly popular
among my friends in Silicon Valley and
across the country because they provide
the same high end financial advice that
the best private wealth managers
delivered some ultra wealthy but for any
account size and at a fraction of the
cost for instance they monitor your
portfolio every day across more than a
dozen asset classes to look for
opportunities to rebalance or harvest
tax losses now would you do the same are
you doing the same probably not and the
power is in the software wealthfront now
manages more than four billion dollars
in assets which is up from around 2.5
billion when they started advertising on
this podcast they're growing incredibly
quickly unlike old-fashioned private
wealth matters wealthfront is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax-efficient low-cost hassle-free way
to invest they don't have loaded sales
teams or retail locations so they can
deliver all of this sophisticated
financial advice and these services at a
fraction of the cost of a traditional
financial advisor so the very least go
to wealthfront calm forward slash tim
and take their free risk assessment
survey it only takes a couple of minutes
and well front will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money so even
if you don't use their service you have
a huge leg up and you have additional
information for making good decisions
they use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make but
should so go too well front calm forward
slash Tim to get your first 15k managed
for free or just to get more details
check it out well front calm forward
slash temp this episode is brought to
you by for sig Matic I reached out to
the finish entrepreneurs after a very
talented Acrobat introduced me to one of
their products which blew my mind and
the best way possible it is mushroom
coffee what on earth is this well it
includes chaga mushroom very powerful
antioxidants considered a superfood I
was introduced to chaga by Laird
Hamilton the king of big-wave surfing of
all things and it includes another
mushroom that is considered a no tropic
a smart drug and this is lion's mane in
the entire package just added the hot
water tastes like coffee there is only
40 milligrams of caffeine so less than
half what you would find in a cup of
coffee so you I do not get any jitters I
do not get any acid reflux or any type
of stomach burn and it put me on fire
for an entire day and I only had half of
the packet so this stuff is really
amazing people are always asking me what
I use for cognitive enhancement right
now this is the answer so it is legal it
will not give you visuals that's
something else and you can try it right
now by going to force Sigma takam
forward slash Tim that is for sig Matic
SI GM atic for Sigma deck comp org slash
Tim and use the code Tim to get twenty
percent off your first order if you are
in the experimental minds that i do not
think you'll be disappointed for sigmata
calm fold / yep
[Applause]